The big news of the day is that Democrats
in the house of representatives have announced
to
articles of impeachment against president
Donald Trump. It's happening. This is still
merely the beginning, even though it feels
like we are, uh, very far into it, including,
I mean, we are dozens and dozens of hours
into livestreams of all sorts of different
hearings, but still, we are only now sort
of getting to the real meat of it this morning,
a Nancy Pelosi with an initial statement followed
by a Jerry Nadler, chairman of the house judiciary
committee announcing articles of impeachment
followed by Adam Schiff, chair of the house
intelligence committee detailing the evidence
for each of those two. And this is going to
be a big battle and it's going to be a political
battle. Importantly, as much as, as it is
going to be a battle around the evidence.
Two articles of impeachment charging Donald
Trump. The first article is for abusive power.
The president, uh, Democrats say exercising
powers of public office to obtain improper
personal benefit while ignoring or injuring
the national interest.
What does that mean in practice? Well, this
is what they say Donald Trump did when he
solicited and pressured Ukraine to influence
our election. And thus it is impeachable because
it violates his oath. Say Democrats, this
will be now adjudicated in a Senate trial
assuming the house votes to go forward consistent
with previous, uh, invites that Donald Trump
made in 2016. It was noted noted by Jerry
Nadler, although that is not actually what
Donald Trump is being impeached for. And that
is going to be a question Mark, which is when,
uh, um, uh, the impeachment hearings started,
there were assertions that they should have
included the emoluments clause. They should
have included Trump's dealings with the Yemen
fiasco that they should have included. Um,
some of the obstruction that the Mueller report
indicated Donald Trump participated in, but
they don't. And that is going to be part of
Democrats, Republicans, defense.
We will get to that a little bit later. Now,
article two is obstruction of Congress. And
that actually relates to Donald Trump's reaction.
When Congress started investigating article
one when the impeachment inquiry was started,
Donald Trump Democrats say engaged in defiance
of the inquiry, which leads to another impeachment
article obstruction of Congress. Democrats
said today that Donald Trump by his, when
the inquiry was announced, declared himself
above accountability that the American people
were subjugated by Donald Trump. Uh, his behavior
that Donald Trump declared himself above the
impeachment power of Congress, which is a
constitutionally enshrined power. And that
is count number two. Now, Adam Schiff explained
what the evidence is and one of the things
I like about how Adam Schiff is approaching
this is that he made it about the evidence
tells us we must impeach ignoring the political
sitter considerations. Now, there are political
considerations and I'm going to talk to them,
but I have said from the beginning that calculating
whether the impeachment process is likely
to succeed or not, or how it is likely to
affect the democratic primary.
Those are perfectly reasonable things to discuss.
But when we are talking about something as
serious and infrequently used as not the power
of impeachment, but the duty of impeachment
when the facts warranted, there should not
be political considerations and we're going
to get to that now. Adam Schiff continued
to lay out the evidence that they have during
this morning's announcement, pointing out
that Donald Trump's solicited Ukraine to publicly
announce investigations into a political opponent
or, or a a, an expected political opponent,
Joe Biden, in order to help his own campaign.
This is an abuse of the power of the office
of the presidency and that two specific official
acts were conditioned upon at least the announcement
of those investigations. Number one, the release
of military aid to Ukraine and number two,
a white house meeting for the Ukrainian president
Adam Schiff said, this jeopardizes the integrity
of the 2020 election.
It jeopardizes the integrity and sovereignty
of the United States to run its own elections
free from this type of foreign meddling and
Adam Schiff claims to have overwhelming evidence
of all of this and then laying out the evidence
for count number two, obstruction of Congress
that once the news of the impeachment inquiry
or potential impeachment inquiry went public,
uh, that Donald Trump obstructed Congress
shifts as he has all of the evidence. Now,
one of the critiques all along this entire
thing, this entire inquiry, and now the articles
should include Donald Trump's emoluments violations,
emoluments clause violations. I believe that
that is absolutely correct and it is too late
for that now and the attempt to add anything
in now, whether it's about 2016 interference
other than merely providing context or a monuments
or whatever else would be no question seized
done by Republicans to try to discredit the
entire thing saying, look, it was about this,
and you said it was about this initially and
now you're pulling in these other issues.
I think it would be a strategically a mistake,
although politically there may be some benefit
to it. Donald Trump immediately starting to
tweet, including about the U S MCA, this trade
deal that he's been talking about for awhile.
Also upon learning that Democrats would be
announcing this today just before the hearing
started, Donald Trump tweeting to impeach
a president who has proven through results,
including producing perhaps the strongest
economy in our country's history, to have
one of the most successful presidencies ever
and more importantly who has done nothing
wrong is sheer political madness. Hashtag
2020 election. Now, what's important to understand
about this is that Donald Trump has refrained,
uh, has continued to use this refrain, uh,
time and time again at rallies, during interviews,
et cetera, which is how do you impeach a president
who's doing just such a good job? And that
is exactly the misunderstanding about impeachment
that Donald Trump and many on the right seem
to have impeachment is not about from the
point of view of Democrats.
Can we, is this going to help us or hurt us
in 2020, what's this going to do to Bernie
and Warren if it pulls them off of the campaign
trail to be at a Senate trial? It is not about
that. It is about what do the facts say given
what impeachment is supposed to be for on
the same, uh, along the same lines. But on
the other side is this idea from Trumpists
and from Republicans that if the stock market
is doing well, the president shouldn't be
impeached. That is not what this is about.
That was never what impeachment was meant
to be for. Uh, and um, the, the, the continued
either misunderstanding or disingenuous, deliberate
misstatement about the parameters of impeachment
is tricking a lot of trunk pistons. A parroting
that line. The economy's doing really well.
How, how is it that you can impeach a president?
Well, the two things have nothing to do with
each other. So now what? Well, now the judiciary
committee of the house is going to meet, they
will examine the articles and they will make
a recommendation to the house. Eventually
the house will vote. Now, there was a report
this morning that that vote would happen on
December 12th. That's just 48 hours from now.
Uh, I don't know if that still is the plan.
Uh, Jerry Nadler didn't mention it during
his speech. Anyway, we will see. Then we would
move. A importantly that requires only a 50%
plus one of vote in the house to move forward.
We would then be moving forward to a Senate
trial. There is speculation that that could
be in January. As of last week, the Senate's
calendar for 2020 starts in February. They
left January blank presumably to account for
the possibility of the impeachment trial and
that could lead to a Senate impeachment trial
of the president of the United States.
That wraps up just before the first 2020 democratic
primary votes start being cast on February
3rd in Iowa in the Iowa caucus, and that's
where we start getting into the political
implications, but it's important to separate
them. We want to separate the political implications
and possible repercussions of this impeachment
from the duty to do this because the facts
say that impeachment is proper shifted. This,
he explained we won't get anywhere if we wait.
There were arguments, politically motivated
arguments about maybe it's better to wait.
The timing could be better. This that. The
other time Adam Schiff pointed out, the white
house has been ignoring our requests. It took
months just to get a court to say that Donald
Trump's attorney, Don McGahn must testify.
It's still not clear that the guy is going
to testify. If he does, he is going to assert
executive privilege and or invoke his fifth
amendment right.
So that was well said by Schiff saying, let's
wait, is saying let's let him maybe cheat
again in an election or let's let them cheat
one more time in an election and that that
doesn't make any sense. Adam Schiff rightly
framing this as we're defending the constitution,
period. That's what we have to do. Impeachment
has happened only three times before Andrew
Johnson and bill Clinton, both of whom were
acquitted in the trials. In other words, with
Andrew Johnson and bill Clinton, the house
said via a majority vote simple majority.
Let's go forward. There was a Senate trial
and the Senate voted to acquit. You then had
Richard Nixon, Richard Nixon resigned before
the Senate trial. Of course under the assumption,
the overwhelming pressure that he was under,
knowing that Republicans were going to turn
on him in the Senate because Republican voters
had turned on him and he resigned to avoid
ultimately being convicted on impeachment.
So there has never been an impeachment conviction
for a president in the history of the United
States. I don't expect there to be one this
time and we're going to get into into that.
We're going to get to that in a second. The
Senate trial, which would be held, would be
presided over by the chief justice of the
Supreme court, John Roberts. And then you
need two thirds of the Senate to vote to convict,
to remove the president of the United States.
As of right now and in January, which will
still be the same Senate. That means you need
20 Republicans. Where does that math come
from? There are 45 Democrats in the Senate.
There are two independence, uh, Bernie Sanders
and Angus King who caucus with the Democrats
and would be expected, or at least for our
math, we should assume they vote to impeach.
That's 47. You need 67 meaning you need 20
Republicans.
Now, in the most optimistic case Senator from
Connecticut, Chris Murphy said, as I told
you yesterday, he knows of maybe a handful
of Republicans that would consider it, consider
voting to convict Donald Trump. Even if he's
right and you get five even if he gets twice
as many and he gets 10 you're still short
by 10 so I don't see this as getting Trump
out via a conviction, but it does appear to
be the correct thing to do simply because
it's what the evidence says needs to happen,
not necessarily what's most politically advantageous.
Now that being said, let's get to the political
implications. It could be good for Democrats,
it could be bad for Democrats. A Trump acquittal
in the Senate could completely reinvigorate
Trump and his followers who say he has been
vindicated after the Russia probe and the
impeachment hoax as they are calling them.
And there may even be some 2016 Trump voters
who still on paper support Trump, but they're
kind of disillusioned and maybe they were
planning on staying home. It could really
reinvigorate the pro Trump electorate. And
it could rocket Donald Trump to reelection
in 2020 that's one possibility. The other
way it could go is the Senate trial is devastating
to Donald Trump. A couple of Republicans do
turn, but not enough to convict Donald Trump,
and it feels as though this guy has again,
escape the consequences and a sense of justice
makes people invigorated to go out and vote
for somebody else. That could also happen.
I'm not feeling like it's hugely likely. The
Republican response and strategy we already
know is an effective one, which is attack.
The entire thing is a preplanned a farce.
Democrats decided back in 2017 they were going
to do this. There's no evidence.
The real story is Hunter Biden. They will
say it was all hearsay, which of course is
both untrue and misunderstands. That hearsay
is a type of evidence. Remember, these are
not criminal proceedings, so that is a red
herring, but those have been effective strategies
so far. Last thing, political implications
for Democrats. There's an idea floating around
that impeachment in total, like from the get
go. Impeachment is an establishment democratic
strategy to deny Bernie or Warren, their nominations,
possible nominations as the democratic nominees.
The story being the Senate trial is going
to pull Bernie and Warren off of the campaign
trail at exactly the right time. It'll tie
them up and it will get Joe Biden more attention.
It'll leave Joe and Pete, Buddha, judge and
other establishment candidates out there by
themselves without Bernie or Warren. I don't
think that that would work. Number one, since
Bernie and Warren being part of the trial
would get them likely lots of free TV time
that could help them.
Number two, the trial is likely to happen,
uh, in the few weeks leading up to the first
caucus in Iowa and then they will again be
free to go and campaign as we approach super
Tuesday and all of those other days. So I
just don't think if that is the strategy,
I think it's a pretty poor strategy to deny
Bernie and Warren the nomination a lot here,
a lot going on. Let me know your thoughts
or leave a reply if you're watching on YouTube,
of course, after liking this video. Otherwise
send me a tweet at Dee Pacman. Follow me on
Twitter. A lot of this stuff.
Gotcha happening there